hello everyone i'm alan and welcome to
my channel where today we are playing
elden ring and answering your most
common questions about them i have some
700 i think so far comments uh and i
pulled the ones that seemed the most
common to me um i'm just gonna walk
around
kind of the opening area of the game
right now um the one that you will have
seen if you saw the network test i don't
want to spoil anything so we're not
going to head anywhere too deep we'll
just kind of stay around here while we
go through the most common questions
that you guys had about elderly so the
first one uh the most common question
was people asking if they aren't into
dark souls or haven't liked other prom
soft games will they enjoy this game and
um
i will say i think this game is very
very similar uh to dark souls
specifically it is more like dark souls
than bloodborne or sakura and it is
much more like dark souls than
the other two games that i just
mentioned have been new ip if that
sentence makes sense basically i'm
saying
this game feels more like dark souls 4
though it does still do a lot of new
stuff too enough that i think it
deserves its new ip but it feels more
like dark souls 4
than bloodborne and sakuro ever felt
like dark souls it is not as unique as
those two games um
when it comes to fromsoft's ips um so in
my opinion if you don't like
dark souls i don't think you're likely
to really gravitate towards uh elden
ring it kind of depends on why you don't
like dark souls specifically but it is
very much in the same vein i feel like
it's really obvious in
all of the ui um everything like your
equipment menu it's going to look really
really similar
uh the combat is very very similar to
dark souls there are some changes but
yeah ultimately
it's it's
more similar to dark souls than not and
some people ask me you know
would i recommend
this as a starting point to be your
first from some game and
my answer is actually no i'm not going
to tell you that i wouldn't recommend
playing this game because i think this
game rules i think it is really really
really good um it's fantastic however
i actually think it kind of assumes that
you have
some tidbits of knowledge um it seems to
treat you a little bit like you have
played previous games so
i would actually recommend that you
start with dark souls 1. then the next
most common question that i got was
about the difficulty um people are
asking me if it is as hard as previous
souls games and i feel like some of that
conversation uh came from fromsoft
themselves i believe saying that they
felt like this one
was the most approachable um
and
my answer to that is yes and no
i largely feel like this game is
obviously stealth is a thing which is
handy
um i feel like this game is
just as difficult um especially where
boss fights are concerned uh just
where everyone is concerned honestly um
just as difficult as previous games
the difference
is that some players may find it a
little bit more approachable
because the open world lets you fast
travel at really any point in time
and
not any point in time i should say there
are some things that are locked away um
but you can fast travel so if you're in
an area where you feel like things are a
little bit too hard you can just
turn around and leave and that's not to
say that that hasn't existed in some
form or another in previous souls games
or
previous prom soft games but i mean
right now you know if i were to find any
of these a little bit too hard oh okay i
haven't gone in here in this uh in this
playthrough um
i could just teleport somewhere else and
try again i could just try a completely
different strategy um that is obviously
completely doable
um and this is an example of what i was
talking about i'm pretty sure that i
went inside this game in the network
test and i'm not gonna go in here
because
oh it's open anyway
i'm doing it even though i'm trying to
record a q a um i'm like but what if but
what if i did
uh
the sense of wonder in this game
my god like
constant curiosity not that that hasn't
been the case for me in other souls
games as well or in other fromsoft games
but in this one i'm just like
the sense of wonder that i feel like
only breath of the wild really pulls off
um
there are a few games that kind of
manage to do it but
you're just in awe all the time like
whoa what's going on like what am i
looking at right now this is obviously a
turtle with a very hard shell
but every dungeon i'm like
what kind of enemy is going to be in
there or like what loot's going to be in
there it's just like
it's so
so so exciting um and obviously yeah
there is a lot of stuff to loot which is
what i'm walking around doing right now
oh a skull see it just happens all the
time there's so much stuff that you'll
find and be like oh that's cool and some
of it's giant and terrifying question
here says is there more narrative
exposition relative to other from
software games a major point of
contention for me has been from
storytelling approach um i understand
that it can certainly require a little
bit more of you than most games do um
i feel like
the storytelling in this game is still
pretty obtuse
it's still
uh
a little more complex than your average
video game see i want to go up there
what's that i want to go look at
whatever this statue is
oh i've already played this you know so
yeah it's still definitely obtuse it's
not like you're gonna get attached to
the characters in the story in the same
way that you might in a more traditional
um
you know like your traditional open
world game like a skyrim
or whatever however
when i thought about it when i really
thought about this question i i do think
it does streamline the narrative a
little bit um and supposedly that gets
better as the game goes on so supposedly
the more you play the clearer it will be
who the different factions are and kind
of the political leanings of um
the style of writing that george uh
martin is known for kind of comes out
around the
the hour mark
i don't know how long it actually takes
to get to that point
but uh i don't feel like it happened
necessarily immediately but it seems
like it's gonna be a little bit easier
though it's still
not
you know gonna be like goes to tsushima
or um
yeah oblivion or skyrim or whatever
other big fantasy open worlds you might
be thinking of i got a few questions
here about co-op i have not actually
tried the co-op myself but um a number
of friends tried it and
it's pretty janky it has some strange
limitations like you can't really play
the game in full in co-op it counts
dungeons and the open world as separate
instances so you have to play you know
this part of the open world i could be
running around with a friend but
basically anytime that you want to go
into a dungeon
it is going to require you to um
rejoin games with each other and there
are network issues it's certainly not
perfect so it's there
but i don't feel like it's really up to
par with um
the industry standard for the most part
one thing you're also seeing there is um
this game does have in my opinion a lot
of frame rate drops um i'm playing on pc
with a 3080
yeah you'll you'll see them throughout
the course of this i feel like it's very
very frequent that we see frames drop
unfortunately questionnaire says does
the open world feel alive and lived in
let me tell you okay
it's a unique open world it it has its
own style um
it doesn't feel like like alive in a way
that maybe red dead redemption 2 does
where
you know things are just
organically running across the path and
obviously i'm still seeing wildlife but
i don't feel like they necessarily are
doing anything other than waiting for me
to show up to them in a lot of cases
however
this
is one of my favorite open worlds i have
ever experienced in any game ever
and by a significant margin
and the thing that gives it that status
for me is
it's
it's just got so much in it
and all of the stuff it has in it the
sense of wonder that comes with that
oh it's it's
unbelievable the amount of stuff that
you will find you're like okay what is
this what is that thing what happens if
i go to the base of the tree these are
all questions that
you would think that would be just a
bunch of walking in between just we're
just gonna have to walk a lot maybe i
gotta climb something
the amount of surprises and points of
interest that this game throws at you
i'm so impressed that it got made i
can't
i can't even begin to describe how
impressed i am
with the density
of the open world and how populated it
is and how full of cool landmarks it is
it is absolutely incredible there are
just so many things on the map that are
so interesting and so much enemy variety
in a way that like
i'm i'm just so excited playing it all
the time it is
absolutely phenomenal do i think it's
game of the year worthy absolutely yes
a lot of good games coming out this year
um but i would be shocked if this game
doesn't win
at least one person's game of the year
it's and i haven't even come close to
finishing it it's huge obviously huge i
don't even know how long it actually is
because nobody that i've spoken to uh
who also got access to it early has
managed to finish it nobody's rolled
credit supposedly you can finish it in
about 30 hours um
i would not recommend rushing through
the story because the appeal of it is i
mean yeah those bosses are cool
but the appeal really is in
this incredible open world have you used
the magic and how cool is it okay so
there are a number of different kinds of
magic uh i will actually choose not to
spoil a lot of them for you
but i can show you this one which is one
of my absolute favorites
wolves go
then we just gotta aggro someone i guess
or they won't and they will just help me
fight everybody
um
your little summons you can get loads of
different kinds of summons you can level
them up in different ways they are
very cool uh we'll fight all kinds of
fights with you very very fun companions
to hang out with so there are these
things here that are called uh ash of
war um storm stomp there is one of my
favorites this is obviously only very
early into the game what you're looking
at right now and then there is actual
like spell casting magic which i don't
currently have unlocked um and there is
more
there are more
things that i would say are akin to
magic that i don't want to spoil
there's a lot going on uh i i think the
combat feels great how is the content or
delivery of side quests uh yeah so there
are a number of side quests and probably
kind of
probably i don't know i feel like some
of the npcs are pretty likable um from
what i've seen
they will give you some
info on to how you know they might
approach you or you might approach them
in some
sort of more unique ways for uh
these games i love rollins through stuff
and some of them are really interesting
in part because of like where you find
them in the world what are you doing
here why do you live here
why do you have this at the front of
your
weird shack it there is some really
interesting stuff but they still kind of
give you some nonsense direction in a
lot of cases where you feel like you
know uh where you're supposed to be
going and you just absolutely do not um
they'll tell you like it's in the swamp
and it turns out it's not in the swamp
it's just like
vaguely near the swamp so
nothing is ever spelt out for you but
i'd be surprised if you expected that
from from this game the next one is how
big is the open world uh the open world
is
enormous it is it is huge i'm not going
to show you the map again i'm intending
to keep this this video completely
spoiler free for everybody um and also
just out of respect for
the dev team of course at this point in
time
but um it is absolutely enormous
it is unfathomably large from my
perspective so far and maybe at some
point i will be able to fathom it but
today is not that day it's just stuff
like this just
cool stuff that you just find and
there's so much of it that i feel like
i'm always finding the cool stuff is it
difficult like wow this is fun difficult
or bad difficult um
i have a bit of trouble answering this
like i had a lot of people ask me how
many controllers i've broken and stuff
like that uh i don't really get very
frustrated playing video games i am not
the right person to ask that kind of
question i'm sorry i have only had fun
um i feel like i've gotten frustrated
potentially a little bit in uh certain
drum soft
arenas in the past um specifically when
i felt like the camera was working
against me
but i don't feel like that has been the
case so much with this one obviously the
frame rate drops can be a little bit of
a nuisance if it's happening
actually
in combat um but that's pretty rare i
think it tends to be mostly when you're
just like turning around in the open
world is it actually structured like an
open world um yes and no in a way that i
think is actually very unique so yes it
is structured like an open world and
that i'm currently in the open world and
i can go wherever i want and do whatever
i want and explore anything that i can
see from here
however there is a a linear means of
progression there is a path forward the
uh sites of grace will lead you towards
those let me go and find one of them but
so we're talking to npcs just talking to
npcs will will give you certain tidbits
of information regarding um oh it's
nighttime so pretty
uh
yeah so certain npcs will also direct
you the right way and
it is
surprisingly easy to
remember in terms of navigation
considering how big it is like it's not
hard to remember where certain things
are because i feel like they do such a
good job of doling out landmarks uh how
is the difficulty relative to the other
from games yeah it's pretty much the
same
it is just as difficult as ever it's
just that now it's easier for you to
leave obviously there's a fast travel i
haven't even used my mount we have a
spectral steed here so it's easy to get
around it's easy to flee you can run
away
so here is one of the grace sites right
here which is also generally how you
will level up
and they will all point in a specific
direction sometimes towards your like
main quest objective um sometimes
towards points of interest in the area
and they are very very frequent
much more frequent than bonfires
sometimes you'll find them like
you know visibly in line of sight with
each other which i've so far found like
mostly confusing i've been like why are
the two
so close together and i think it's
because they're placed
based on points of interest and not on
one another so they could be right next
to each other if there's something to
the left that's interesting and
something to the right that's
interesting
in uh one confined space did it meet my
expectations failed to or completely go
above what i expected
i would actually say it went above what
i expected i feel like fromsoft are so
good
at let's do some mount gameplay here
it can be really hard to hit them but
you can do uh left and right which is
thing i think is pretty cool
based on which bumper you you hit
yeah hitting people on mounts can be
like like i really thought i would use
it a lot more than i did when i started
playing i was like i'm just gonna use it
all the time and they can't hit me it's
like well yeah but if you can't hit them
either
but yeah um i feel like fromsoft are
very very very good at uh
at level design in such a specific way
where like they capture that feeling of
like oh what's this gonna make people
motion sick like what's around this
corner where am i gonna where am i gonna
see next like what could possibly be
here and i was worried that some of the
the genius of that level design would be
lost in an open world but my god did
they prove me wrong um
i was really like i don't know man i
feel like it's maybe
it's not gonna have the same magic
because players can choose where to go
and the way that they combated my
concern was by having interesting things
all the time everywhere in a way that i
just yeah i just feel like i haven't
seen in an open world game it's
it's nuts so yeah i was worried that
that
we would lose some of the good level
design because it's not individual
levels for the most part
i feel like i was wrong i apologize
fromsoft you did
still manage to execute on amazing level
designs just
in the specific towns that you venture
into or the biomes that you visit it oh
it's so good
some people asking what elden ring
itself is i will tell you there's an
emote uh that i'm a really big fan of
which i currently don't have equipped
here we go little elden ring of mutt
they just slowly
i'm such a big fan of that does it
suffer from open world syndrome or is it
more unique i do not think it suffers
from open world syndrome i will show you
the map
and i'm just gonna keep it real close
right so we're just gonna if i just
stick to kind of this area i don't think
it does because the only markers that
you're seeing here these um
that's where i am right now um sites of
grace that's it so because they're
really the only markers there there are
a couple of other things that you will
occasionally see on the map and of
course you can like place beacons
yourself and then that will
give you the hud there which is like a
very nice quality of life thing um
oh one thing that they did improve that
i really like is that you can now see
how much you weigh you don't do
percentages it'll tell you if you're low
uh medium heavy which is awesome and
yeah you can mark different things too
so you have these options to like be
like oh a skull go there
um then you can obviously remove them
just by going over them but no it that's
it the markers are all either yours or
just grace sites so i feel like it
doesn't suffer from
the open world syndrome that a lot of
other games do because you don't just
have a long checklist of markers that
you need to
complete or visit or get xp from it is
much more exploration driven in a way
that i really really love is it true
that swamps are numerous and miserable
no because even in this game i'm not
gonna take you to one even in this game
um the swamps are colorful they have
swamps that are like pink or red
yeah it's not it's not a dreary game it
is very very colorful it's the prettiest
game that they've ever made maybe next
to sakura which is obviously pretty
beautiful but i mean it it's very you
know high fantasy
i just think it's gorgeous
all the time it's just so
nice to look at it's incredible and at
this point we are
covering over the questions that i've
been asked the most which is what i
wanted to keep this video to obviously
this is very surface level i'm sure uh
souls fans will already know most of the
stuff that i said but this is vast
majority the question i'm seeing now are
the same things so i think i will leave
it there i don't want to i just don't
want to get boy too much um i like want
to be like everyone should try this game
i think it rules but it's also
absolutely not for everyone and that's
totally okay but yeah very big thank you
to bandai namco for giving me a code so
that i could play the game early you are
seeing a save that is about six hours in
right now which is actually from my
let's play series that will be going up
tomorrow with my friends john and jacob
but otherwise um yeah just try to keep
this spoiler free and answer those most
common questions i hope you guys enjoyed
this video
i'm gonna keep playing this game i will
see you guys next time bye